[Music]
okay so hi my name is Whitney Williams
and I'm from Greenville South Carolina I
work at the quote Center in Vancouver
Washington and my job is to translate
design thinking and UX principles into
performant friendly user friendly
front-end code so why am I here today
I'm here Q sparked a conversation about
the legacy of the JavaScript community
and I've talked to a lot of you already
about like what does this mean and like
what is your talk about and like I've
given away a little piece of it but
hopefully I've saved enough to make it
worth your while to stay until the very
end of the conference if you have
questions you can follow me on Twitter
my name is Whitney hacks and I'm also
happy to talk to you after the
conference at the after party where
finally I can get excited and not have
to go to bed early um so I'd like to
start with a story and the story is
pretty simple
so when I was a little girl every
morning I was really terrible at
brushing my hair and that seems like oh
yeah how does this fit into a JavaScript
conference I promise it's coming so when
I was little I was really terrible at
brushing my hair and every morning my
mom would help me and she'd help me
brush it out and so every morning I had
a question for her and that question
that I had for my mom was hey mom you
know what do you think I'm going to be
when I grow up and my mom came up with a
different answer every morning and so
one morning she told me Whitney I think
you're going to be an astronaut and then
I grew up a little bit and I went to
Space Camp and I'm math mama hey mom
what am I going to be when I grew up and
then she would say you know I think you
could be a baker and I would look at my
granddad and he was a baker and I would
think yeah gosh
you know I think I could be a baker too
and then I kept asking her these
questions and every morning she would
tell me a different answer and finally I
woke up one morning and I realized that
she wasn't going to give me an answer
that was right
she couldn't predict the future and so I
just stopped asking it was just it was
that sudden but I think it's that simple
routine that really cemented my belief
that I could do anything
but telling that story the reason I tell
you is because I think small actions
have a really big impact in the world
and in JavaScript were so wrapped up in
immediacy we're so wrapped up in seeing
results like right now and we've heard
so many people talk about like shaving
off milliseconds and when it comes to
JavaScript like that stuff is really
really cool but it also has sort of a
darker back side where we sort of forget
that the actions that we take right now
can sometimes take months or even years
to see the full effect and when I talk
about full effect I'm talking about in
the community not just in the browser
but in the people that surround us and
so what's in a seamless or small trivial
almost kitschy behaviors can become
really really significant in ways that
we didn't imagine and so when I told you
that story about me brushing my hair it
seemed a little bit silly but I think it
was really impactful in how I sort of
saw myself as a person in the world like
what can i really be when i want to grow
up and so throughout this talk what i
want you to think about is not just sort
of who you can be when you grow up who
can the community be who can javascript
be what can we do when we sort of push
our community forward what's it going to
look like in the future
so I think another thing to think about
is our community really needs leaders
and so as the JavaScript community and
the people is the people who embrace
JavaScript grow it becomes ever more
important that we need the same kind of
like kind gentle guidance that my mom
gave me when I was a little kid but the
big thing is that it's not going to be
sort of like a parent or a standards
body like Kasey 39 maybe leaves the way
and says you know this is what is going
to happen it's not going to come from
one individual person and it's not going
to come from a tiny little group of
people but instead leadership is going
to come by the many and not by the few
so it's not one person it's all of us
and so it's the responsibility of all of
us to just you know come together and
determine the legacy of the JavaScript
community so when I say legacy like what
what is legacy even mean I think a lot
of times in software we tend to
associate the word legacy and
specifically legacy in the sense of code
as being old as being broken as being
irrelevant as being something that's
really almost always negative like when
was the last time that you heard someone
talk about legacy software and like a
really great and exciting way and they
were like gosh you know I really can't
wait to get this on my machine working
on and I think that's sort of sad
because originally when the word legacy
originated in the 14th century it had a
completely different meaning and so that
meant that meaning was a lot more
affirmative a lot more positive and it
was this a body of person sent on a
mission so what I'd like to think of
when I refer to legacy is that this is
who we are as JavaScript errs we are a
body of person sent on a mission to
shape the world not just through our
code but also by our vision for the
future of the language and the people
that surround it so seeing ourselves in
this way like seeing ourselves as part
of this living legacy as stewards of the
greater good is critical for two really
important reasons agency and empowerment
and when I say agency what I mean is
that we don't need to wait for the
permission of someone else to make a
change or to lead or to take charge and
so this ability to shape the direction
and influence the future of our
community like that's super impactful in
this direction is just it's incredible
and when I talk about empowerment what I
mean is that it ensures it by being
active participants rather than passive
bystanders we don't leave the hard work
of caretaking the hard work of inclusion
and the hard work of community to others
like this is everybody's job this is my
job this is your job this is everybody's
job that is the price you pay for being
a member of the JavaScript community
so when I say legacy I'd like to just
really boil it down into two simple
things two simple words and that's
people and purpose and I think a lot of
us it's really difficult to boil stuff
down to just the the most common tiny
little factor that everyone understand
but the purpose of JavaScript is people
and I think a lot of times we get really
mixed up because we think javascript is
a lot of things like JavaScript is
conferences and JavaScript is functions
and like JavaScript is all of these
different things but that's a mistake
JavaScript really is the people and the
community that surrounds the language
and the people that interact with it
rather than just the language itself so
what I'd like to say when I say legacy
of the JavaScript community when I think
about that legacy what I think of is not
JavaScript and like what new features
are we going to add and like how are we
going to make it faster how are we going
to make it more impactful like how are
we going to get it running and all the
browser's so super fast and it offline
first and all these things like those
are all great but people first always so
when we need to find our vision our
ideas about the legacy of the JavaScript
community maybe it makes a little bit
more sense to sort of step back in
history before a sort of attempt to have
merged this path forward so when you
think about it from the very very
earliest days of a lot of JavaScript has
been a foundational technology and
despite the central role and something
really unfortunate has happened and I
think what's happened is that a lot of
people tend to look down on us as
JavaScript developers and so dokdo
lovers who write primarily javascript or
sometimes sort of consider less than
developers who write code from other
languages and a lot of times it's
because we say well you know javascript
has really broad appeal and a lot of
people can get started with JavaScript
and it's you know it's relatively easy
to use and so we sort of used this as
evidence that JavaScript has an inferior
status
but it's not a real programming language
but you're not a real developer and I
think you know that's that's just it's
flat-out wrong to be honest so these
classifications are they're just they're
misguided and I think when we look at
javascript as a language it brings to
light a lot of JavaScript subtleties and
the language reveals that javascript is
actually really really nuanced and
complex and we look at JavaScript when
you think you know oh I've got this
totally figured out I'm going to run my
function and then you run it and you
think up what wait and that's that's a
lot how we sort of need to think about
the JavaScript community on the surface
JavaScript may seem incredibly simple
and it may seem really easy to just
apply these stereotypical programmer
tropes to say I know what a JavaScript
developer looks like but on further
inspection I think that these cliches
you know they're just they're wrong
they're not only wrong but they're
untrue they're baseless they're harmful
they're misguided they're limiting and
that's something that I really like to
change so who are we as a community and
if we sort of brush aside these silly
ideas who are we really and what does
being a community in the modern age
really mean I think honestly community
in its simplest form can be defined as a
group of members who share common
characteristics or interests and who
often possess a common cultural and
historical heritage and so some of you
might when I say common cultural and
historical heritage might be getting a
little bit shaky stick with him here for
a second so I think again a superficial
glance at this definition can lead us in
the wrong direction and looking at you
today what I see is incredible diversity
and having listened to all the talks
I've also heard a lot of diversity and a
lot of support for diversity and you
know we're people of all ages were
people of all genders for people of all
backgrounds for people of all different
sorts of beliefs and a lot of us have
different mother tongues that's
something as notice that JavaScript
prompt you in particulars that there's a
lot of different spoken languages and we
also come from a lot of different places
and so the punch
that's printed on our passport may not
actually be the country that we most
identify with and maybe it's just a one
part of an incredibly larger more
detailed story so having heard all of
the talks having listened to people in
the hallway having sort of seen everyone
interact and seeing people treat each
other with so much love and respect what
I'd like to say is that it's clear that
the characteristics and the interests
that we share revolve around JavaScript
and programming and around this need to
make and build and that's something that
regardless of where you come from
regardless of what gender you are
regardless of how old you are like
JavaScript and this need to make cool
stuff like that is something that we all
share so when I talk about heritage I'm
not talking about our genetics I'm not
talking about a physical place or spoken
language and put a belief in the power
of the web and most importantly it's not
these differences or it's not despite
these differences but actually because
of these differences that we're so
uniquely prepared to share in the
mission of a web so the web is here to
stay and because of that we as
JavaScript errs as individuals and as a
community we're obligated to sort of
create and maintain the culture of the
ideas the beliefs that will be carried
forth by the next generation of
JavaScript and those in a future that's
so distant that we can hardly imagine
what it's going to become so the culture
that we create today is going to go
forth and shape the next generation of
JavaScript errs whether we actually
intend for it to or not that's something
that's going to happen so one of the
things I think is really really
important is that javascript is open to
all it's one of the languages most
compelling features it is openness and
so even before we write our first
function many of us were sort of looking
into other people's websites and viewing
the source and trying to figure out you
know how do they do that what did they
do what did they write that native
particular thing happen and so we might
not understand how code actually
work we might not understand what makes
it useful or who wrote it but it's just
the simple act of opening the control
panel and viewing this source and just
and being curious is instrumental
because we might not consider ourselves
developers yet at this point but I would
say that it's this curiosity and it's
just desire to understand JavaScript to
this desire to understand what's going
going on during the hood that actually
grants us memberships to the community
and I think a lot of times when we're
trying to sort of design these barriers
to entry is like who is a JavaScript or
like who gets to label themselves as a
developer what we hear a lot of times is
negativity and we hear this sort of
community of voices that would like to
set up barriers that I think they're
just they're wrong and they're silly and
they're are not helpful and we we limit
membership because we're trying to sort
of get a handle on things and so what we
end up hearing a lot of times from
people who maybe have good intentions
but go about things the wrong way is
stuff like you know these people are not
developers these people don't belong
these people don't use JavaScript the
same way that I use JavaScript and so
they don't struggle with the same
concepts that I'm struggling us you know
they're probably just pretending they're
not real JavaScript er and you know what
that's that's just wrong like that's
just not true
[Applause]
so when when they feel as though
defining the JavaScript community in
such a broad way as problematic why is
that like why are we trying to figure
out who we are like why are we trying to
all figure out like who are our people
well really that's like--that's finding
your community that's that's human
nature and that's okay it's okay to want
to know that you belong but when we
create this really broad definition it
has some really interesting side effects
and one of those things is that by
creating this broad definition and it
includes a lot of people that maybe we
wouldn't have initially labeled as
JavaScript developers and that's okay
but I'll give you a couple of examples
of people that you might not think of as
JavaScript developers but going on
forward after today I'd like for you to
maybe you know rethink about that and so
I think it JavaScript developers
includes a ten-year-old that I talked to
hack on his math homework in a
JavaScript for kids class because he
came back to me a couple of weeks later
and said hey I've actually done all of
the code Academy classes for JavaScript
and this is super interesting and this
kid is 10 like holy cow that's
phenomenal and I think that you know the
JavaScript community also includes
people like designers who are maybe
writing CSS most of the time and they
can write you know just enough
JavaScript to get the stuff working and
we may not think of them as JavaScript
developers but we should and I think it
also includes people who are writing
JavaScript you know it's sort of maybe
on the side part time and it's not a
career for them and maybe they're in
college or maybe they're in code school
and they're looking for a new career
when I said code school maybe some of
you sort of schlattman aren't about that
um but I don't when I say code school
what I don't mean is that students
become members as soon as they gradually
what I actually mean is is not they've
built their first website or did they
finish I mean on the very first day of
class like the coming in member of the
JavaScript community is not something
that magically happens because someone
granted you a privilege JavaScript
community membership happens because
you've got pure
you are enough you belong here like
every single one of you belong here you
are enough so just scientists thinking
that we can sort of erect that we can
define a set of rules for who belongs
and the JavaScript community is limiting
and it's defeating and it's wrong so how
do we lead a community that's so super
diverse how do we lead a community
that's so vast and how do we ensure that
it's inclusive now and in the future um
and I think that earlier when we examine
the word legacy
it's time now to also examine the word
leadership and leadership really is just
something pretty simple it's an act or
an instance it's a really fleeting
moment a leader is someone who provides
guidance a leader is someone who
provides direction on the list think
about that a little bit more an actor in
instance if we drive it deeper we find
that leadership isn't a status that's
granted after months of years of slowly
gaining recognition leadership is
something that can be fleeting it can
happen in a moment and then it can
disappear a moment later and thus a
condition is really incredible when you
think about it it's actually quite
empowering because in order to be a true
leader in the JavaScript community you
don't need to be on the stage you don't
need a lot of Twitter followers you
don't need a blog you don't need a deep
understanding of JavaScript itself and
when I think it's really about is that
leadership is not the loudest voice in
the room yeah of course there are things
like technical leadership so researching
a project and understanding the cost and
benefits of different frameworks like
yeah absolutely that's a form of
leadership being able to speak
confidently about what's the right
choice for your project steps leadership
but being a leader showing leadership
can also be entirely
non-technical and also it can simply
mean doing the right thing in the moment
and so what I'm talking about is making
space for marginalized people of the
community to speak what I'm talking
about is listening when even when you
think that you already know the best
making the effort to use the correct
pronouns for someone not the preferred
pronouns just the ones that are right
and I think what's really important is
that being a leader is not being the
loudest voice in the room being a leader
is actually not about having experience
it's just about helping others learn
it's about creating a culture where it's
okay to make mistakes it's okay to be
wrong it's okay to sort of say hey I I
don't know something and it's not a
culture where we invite retribution it's
not a culture where you know we we sort
of start to pile on and say oh yeah you
shouldn't have done that what instead we
want to create is a culture where we we
have kind constructive feedback where
being a leader is not you know doing the
right thing when it's easy being a
leader is doing the right thing when
it's hard like especially when it's hard
um but a thing that I'd also like to say
is that you know really before we
continue I want to step back and sort of
think about something and there was a
really really great talk yesterday that
touched on this and unfortunately one
aspect of the tech community is that
sadly leadership and participation are
just not equally attainable to everyone
and I think that's you know it's just
it's frustrating and if it's bad and
it's wrong and then and so being here
being part of this community being part
of this conference being part of just
the world at large the boundaries that
are faced by membership by members of
the JavaScript community are they're
just they're really harmful and are
harmful not just to this one individual
but they're harmful to the entire
community because they obstruct access
and progress to the individual
they they sort of also create these
ripple effects that we don't see until
later on sort of like when I said you
know I wanted to grow up to be something
and my mom couldn't predict the future a
lot of times when we talk about
leadership and we talk about small
actions being nice to someone making
space for someone letting someone speak
may seem like an incredibly small thing
to you in the moment but 10 years later
it may be that tiny moment that they see
is like the pinnacle of how they started
to feel like they were truly part of the
JavaScript community so I think
ultimately being a part of this
community those of us with more power
with more voice with more privilege what
we really need to do is to try and
remove the barriers for other people
barriers that are both seen and unseen
but we need to remove the barriers for
these people and support them and
encourage them to face obstacles when we
haven't had to overcome those obstacles
ourselves we can really create real
change so it's the language of the web
javascript is pretty uniquely positioned
in the sense that you know we have a
power to affect the broader community
more than just JavaScript we can really
change the world and so before we sort
of look look back on the people and the
technologies that came before us like
don't be fooled javascript is here for
now and it's going to be here in the
future but it's not always going to be
like that it's really easy to believe
that the blog posts that we read the
podcasts that we listen to the indium
packages and they can't help
repositories that we just know are
always going to be there because we're
downloading them when we're building
with them every day the conference's
that we love the meetups where we gather
we have this tendency to believe that
they're just they're sort of always
there they're like in the atmosphere
they're never going to go away and
that's that's wrong and the reason that
these things are not always going to be
there is because they're built by the
community and so the JavaScript
community like all community is made up
of individuals we're building the price
the tools and the languages of the
future we're shaping the world in
exciting and important ways but without
the people everything else disappears
javascript is underpinned by all of
these individuals new concerns are
taking off one by one by one you could
remove each one of us and JavaScript
sort of might be there but if you took
away all of the people JavaScript does
itself it's just not useful anymore and
so in closing I'd sort of like to leave
you with this every morning when you
wake up when you're sort of getting
ready for the day when you're thinking
about the future and you're thinking
about maybe what you want to be when you
grow up or how you can contribute to the
future I'd like you to think sort of
what can you contribute to the community
what can the community be when it grows
up and he traverses s really different
skills really different ideas on how
best to go about leading and so when
when you think about leading what would
you wish for our community so the beauty
of JavaScript of this community that
we've built in this technology that we
love is that by each of us as
individuals by doing our part by leading
and contributing in ways that don't
actually disguise our diversity but
instead to sort of highlight it
something magical happens javascript
becomes this living legacy of not just
the language but if the people that
built it and so our shared vision of
JavaScript as a language and our
community comes to life and it what it
becomes is like I said before this body
of persons that was sent on a mission to
shape the world not just through code
but also by our vision for the language
and the vision of the future for the
community of people that surround it
Thanks
[Applause]